forza pippo un episodio a ragazzi ho
preso vivo non far vedere la totalità
dei miei outfit e la somma di quelli che
ho vinto perché tipo questo calo vinto
con le tre corone delle tre vittorie che
ho fatto questo quale avevo preso qui
punti altrimenti andati quei livelli e
col dlc quello del pirata ragazzi e
bellissimo dicevo però credo che i
migliori siano effettivamente quelli che
ti sblocchi con le corone perché quelle
sono c'è la fine te le devi meritare
skin
si parte ragazzi colonna sonora adeguata
mentre con questa game copier
spetterebbe partiamo quello rimasto
fermo svegliati zio allora che la
partenza è sempre una cacata perché
tanto che è facile ma io non guardo
neanche più la partenza tutte le volte
che l'ho giocata su un abbastanza io
però mi diletto a cercare di arrivare
prima ogni volta perché quello che vi
spiego sempre in discesa saltate perché
mi aumenta la velocità fidatevi e sono
quelle piccole cose che fanno la
differenza con i fatelo sempre però
ragazzi ormai c'è la partenza io
cazzeggio al telefono ogni tanto quando
di gioco perché anche i miei carreggiate
sono 300 perché l'egitto come la
partenza ormai è proprio niente
porca vacca mihai spodestato da tutti
giampiero talia questa parte grazie va
bene ragazzi l'importante la scrematura
iniziale via fuori alemanno che apple
il mio team fa sempre cagare va bè
ragazzi la tattica giusta di hub si dei
sì lo dico sempre quella di rimanere e
poi rimanere il giusto numero di player
da di un team da una parte il giusto
numero dall'altra c'è quindi gli stessi
e lo stesso numeri giocatori blu da un
lato e lo stesso dall'altro che se non
ci parliamo troppi troppi anelli ok
questo me lo tengo io benissimo questo
qua la donna che the star la madonna che
d'estate lamber due ragazzi siete storti
come la morte
l'abbiamo 16 forza i gialli sta perdendo
siamo troppi di qua troppi blu di qua
quanti blu ci sono dia troppo pochi raga
sempre lo stesso numero di blu da una
parte dall'altra
sennò è un casino bravo qua ci sono solo
noi quindi perfetto perfetto perfetto di
mika e spunta un altro anello
non è una tra le quaranta di casa
facendo un sacco di punti la che abbiamo
fatto più punti nelle altre due squadre
messi insieme all'altro 60 61 ragazzi e
tantissimo fare 61 61 non ho mai visto
fare in realtà io grande squadra bella
partita andiamo avanti ragazzi questo
ragazzi io lo odio l'odio sempre perché
tito ragazzi è orribile ma veramente
culo io seguo gli altri bisogna seguire
una tattica di questo seguire gli altri
mai buttarsi fai fare il lavoro sporco
agli altri perché qua non ha senso
buttare non avremo all'inizio sì tanto
non fa niente nel frattempo però dopo il
lifegate buttarsi non ha senso raga non
buttatevi ok buono buono buono buono
ragazzi butti dai rimane in cui dietro a
lato
lo ha fatto una provata io vado avanti
ho provato anch'io come vado avanti con
torna davanti bravo bravo zio bravo va
bene va bene va bene bene bene
nell'email mi ha fatto un casino allora
che siamo in finale speriamo non venga a
quello della corona dove devi
raggiungere colore perché lì è quello
che soffro di più in realtà io adesso
sono in stato bravo in ex a qualcosa
vuole dove rimane ecco infatti riuscita
la corona manco a chiamarla all'inizio
non ero bravino poi mi sono skillato la
morire in quello sono un fenomeno adesso
in questo quale la corona va veramente
troppa cura secondo me è equa volo
dipendere scoppino che non arriva la
sala salita qua ragazzi non cambia
niente
perfetto non è male non è male non è
male non è male
occhio ma che culo quelli a lato sarà
nando velocissimo e occhio miyake fallo
schivato però che questi cadono adesso
seguire sempre la rotazione di sì affari
ragazzi ok buono no dai che sfiga per un
niente
che sfortuna raga per un niente sale
auto iii vabbè dai ci sta come partita
peccato perché forcole moniti dei machi
[ __ ] se sostanza la ogni avvio
bellissimo
no ragazzi spettacolare a non è né
soltanto forse capita che ti da
regolamenti peccato se arrivato terzo
però niente male come partita mi è
piaciuta l 1 leghe madonna quanta gente
che ha scioccato o sono buoni maledetti
anticipato mini che cacchio allora provo
sempre a strà yard aree con quella in
mezzo che non mi serve mai perché
muoiono b come l'ape core sempre infatti
non mi è mai servito però mi piace
traguardare ragazzi non so più a dirvi
io mi butto sempre anche una volta lì
perché voglio delle series
ciao ragazzi come è tutto a posto e
stato bello ok perfetto ragazzi non è
male 33 33 e quello della coda fisso che
gli avevo detto ragazzi ai ragazzi la
tattica giusta sempre quella rimanere
mezzo a sti cosi che tanto la gente non
riesce a beccarli è se poi arrivano in
26 cambiate posto però effettivamente è
quello il migliore per portare il
sottosti così qua ragazzi non mi ha
quasi ne so mediche è proprio difficile
poi sarai uno in 60 altro discorso
ciao zio può essere anch'io non vada
visto quello ha detto a praticarsi
ragazzi abbiamo poche cose raga ai miei
compagni che cacchio fanno prendete ste
cose maledette 6 5 4 3 2 1 qualification
perfetto non è male che una delle cose
ragazzi è sempre va sempre un po culo
questo perché dipende chi ti capita
davanti perché è bravissimo però vabbè
dai cioè tifone merito vada vincerà
questo la vince non me ne vado a ok
ragazzi come dico sempre saint cloud
basta non tra yard aree lo si vince
perché tanto non c'è bisogno di essere
velocissimi basta non cadere per terra
nello slime schifoso maledetto melmoso
paolo levatevi talebana ok tutto a posto
tutto super nice
tutti eliminati sono rimasti in 22 sia
rimasta occhio ci siamo 19 remaining
madonna sono primo solo primo il tutto
fra gattino mi sa che non mi tenere
schifoso laico gioca bene gioca pulito
questo vuole arrivare primo davanti a me
ma è una gara tra me e lui praticamente
non mi avrai ma bisogna aspettare un po
di più piuttosto ragazzi perché occhio e
un attimo cadere
let's go for the first one bellissimo
sono stato molto bravo mi è piaciuta non
vuole non vuol dire niente arrivare
primi ma fa niente l'importante ragazzi
la gloria devono capire chi è chi è il
supremo vincitore visto gioco poi vabbè
gli ultimi sei
speriamo non quello della corona mi
piacerebbe fare quello della coda
speriamo che ci seguono la coda come
finale ti prego ti prego hexagon vabbè
dai va bene anche hexagon va venezia con
l'ultima partita che ho vinto l'inter
hexagon vediamo se la mia tattica solita
di hexagon funzione che è quella di
saltare piano su tutte le piattaforme
quindi questa qua 12
niente una fregata baguette dai compagni
ma niente è importante rimanere
tranquilli a lato tanto c'è tutto il
tempo saltare piano su ogni piattaforma
ragazzi questa è la tattica più
funzionale fino ad adesso rimanere così
dovete saltare col tempo giusto io per
adesso non ho mai avuto problemi guarda
due sono già sotto quindi siamo più o
meno nelle tre sono sotto niente male
niente male per niente ragazzi rimaniamo
qua siamo gli unici lidi all non è vero
cacchio ero l'unico nei viola avevo
praticamente vinto avevo vinto la gara
l'unico nei viola che è fra le finali
ok ma questo è caduto dai dai semi
pochini gialli lei forse riprende di
questa roba di gialli come stata
trattata dalla data da battaglia ed
eliminiamo un po musica del duo perfetto
e che ha avuto l'okay c'è un altro nei
gialli e ragazze un altro abbastanza
forte che ha capito la tattica sono
tanto la mia pratica però io rimango
abbastanza messo bene se riesco a cadere
in un soprano perfetto va bene va bene
va bene
ci si lamenta ho fatto una cagata ma non
fa niente sono rimasto nell'ultima sono
rimasti in due dove l'ultimo che partita
ragazzi che partita incredibile che
partita false skateo rimasti in due
tanto vale corner e siamo in due parole
vale correre non mi ha fregato bravo è
stato bravissimo è stato bravissimo
mi ha fregato è stato dato è stato bravo
stato bravo è stato bravo lui perché mi
ha visto andare là era in vantaggio
non si può fare niente e stato bravo
dovevo andare dall'altra parte perché lì
c'è la loro nave non fa niente le prendo
sempre bene le sconfitte suoi ragazzi
allora la mia tastiera si è rotta
spero che vi sia piaciuto il video ci
vediamo lunedì col prossimo video di
paul guys molto carino ormai le tattiche
le so
bisogna solo evitare di far cagate di
poco la finale però le sappiamo tutte
sempre attenti ragazzi ci vediamo al
prossimo episodio di fuga in via carle
se il video è piaciuto e dove sempre noi
ci vediamo domani con lo possiamo bella
ragazza
[Musica]